feminism this newer form of feminism has  given women the power  to be  just like the most heinous man or the  most heinous men in history  right you know the abusers the sexual  abusers the people that used to talk to  people derogatory but giving them the  the get out of not having accountability  for doing it  that's what i believe feminism today has  done i believe it's you can say you know  what [ __ ] men they're this they're trash  and there's no accountability on your  side but see i feel like that's not true  feminism then i think that's just being  a misandrist  at the end of the day like  that's something that's not spoken about  enough though miss andre is not spoken  about enough oh i agree i think that's  like 90 of feminists today if i'm being  honest like  when when i talk to most feminists they  have a slight disdain for men  like even if i say oh we need men in  society like we argue